EUNICE KIM: We
launched a new section
on the Google Play Store
filled with really awesome kids
and family apps.
Those apps are part of our
design for families program.
And for the past
12 months, we've
been continuing to build on the
suite of features and services
that we offer to
families who cross play,
and I wanted to briefly
recap some of our most
recent launches before
we get into the meat
of the presentation.
So first of all,
we've been working
on refining our understanding
of parents as a user segment,
and finding ways
both big and small
to personalize their
experiences on Google Play.
I'll just give you one
small example of this.
This is the family
category quick link
that you're seeing
on the screen.
This is the little
green family button,
and we've made this more visible
for the parent user segment
by placing it front and
center on the Play homepage.
This small change resulted in
a really substantial uplift
for family apps on Google Play.
We've also added on to our most
popular feature for families:
browsing by character.
In the last 12 months
since our launch,
we've added another 34 beloved
characters on the Play Store
globally, including one that
I think everyone in the room
will recognize, and this
is Angry Birds, of course.
And character painted
pages-- they show off
a curated collection of movies,
TV shows, apps and games,
books, and even music albums
associated with the character.
So I don't know if anyone here's
excited to see Angry Birds
the Movie in a couple of days.
I know that my kids are.
They've been watching the
release date pretty closely.
And when Angry Birds the Movie
comes out on Google Play,
you'll be able to find
it all in one place here
on the character page.
And we're making this
page far more discoverable
through search,
through featuring,
et cetera, all across
the Play Store.
Now beyond the store,
we've also been
spending more time
thinking deeply
about how to offer families
more premium services,
and better support family
interactions across Android.
So last December, we launched
the Google Play Music family
plan.
This is a subscription
that gives up
to six people in your family
unlimited music for just
$14.99 a month.
Now, if you were
buying this separately
for each family member, that
would actually cost you $60,
so it's actually a
pretty great value.
And we throw in YouTube
Red on top of that,
so your whole family can
enjoy YouTube ads free.
This is obviously-- here,
you guys are app developers.
Why am I talking to you
about this music plan?
Now when you lift
up the hood, there's
something really
important going on here
that's relevant for our
app developer community.
When you actually get into
these premium services,
you need to create
a family group,
so we start understanding
who's in your family.
And the eligibility for these
types of family services
are anchored around a shared
family payment method.
Now, this really opens up
some interesting possibilities
in terms of interactions
around payments on Google.
As we all know, it's
really difficult
to get users to put
their credit card down,
and a lot of our audience,
children and younger audiences,
they don't necessarily
have access to credit,
or the existing options wouldn't
have been particularly secure
for them.
So with the family
payment method,
family members can buy almost
anything on Google Play,
including paid apps,
in app purchases,
and other kinds of
digital content.
So how does that work exactly?
This is something that's live,
you could test it out yourself.
Let's take a closer
look at this scenario.
Imagine my teenager is playing
Transformers Rescue Bots,
and he wants to buy the
two bots bundle for $5.
Well he doesn't have
a credit card yet,
he used up his
Play gift card that
is grandmother gave
him a month ago,
and instead of
abandoning the purchase,
or worse yet, heckling
me for my credit card,
where I have to add
that to his account,
he can actually use the
family payment method.
For in-app purchases, we
provide the family manager
with a feature called
purchase approvals.
This means that I have to
actually approve the purchase
before it goes through.
Now if it was my husband
making the purchase,
well I don't really want
to bother with all of that
because I do trust him,
so I have the option
of turning this setting off.
And note that the family payment
method is an optional feature
for families.
No one is forced to use it.
Even when you're
part of a family,
it's just one more
additional payment method
that is available for
your family members.
So the family group and
the family payment method
are things we'll be continuing
to build on this year,
and you probably saw a
little note in your inbox
yesterday about family
library, which is coming.
I don't have more to share
about that at this moment,
but you can expect a
little bit more news
on this in a few months.
So with that, let's pivot to
our main topic today, which
is about building
family-friendly apps
and a family-friendly
business on Google Play.
Now we know all of you
sitting in the audience,
you're developers of
kids and family apps.
Some of you are educators.
Some of you are here
because you're parents,
or you're just still
young at heart.
You hear about all the great
Android and Google APIs,
and you're wondering to
yourself can I use that service?
Is there a right way
to use that service
as a kids' app developer?
We know it's hard
to figure out how
to navigate the intersection
of Google and kids apps,
so we wanted to give you
some helpful tips on how
to use our services and APIs.
So, first of all, let's
talk about your apps.
Your app probably falls
into one of these 2 buckets.
Either you're making an app
that's developed primarily
for kids, or you're
making an app
that's meant to be enjoyed
by both kids and adults.
Now, if your app doesn't
fall into either of these two
buckets, then you
probably don't need
to be sitting in this session
unless you're just here
for the air conditioning.
Let's move on.
Just keep it in mind which
type of app you have.
Now, if you have an app that's
designed for kids and families,
here's the easiest
tip of the day
that we'll give you, which
is joining the Design
for Families program.
Why?
Well it's better for
your apps and it's also
better for our users.
So most of you already
know about the benefits
of this program, but I'll
just quickly recap it.
You have an opportunity to
be featured in the family
category on Google Play.
You get to rank and top
chart your family apps,
in addition to regular
top charts in the games
or the apps section.
You can be discovered in
search queries relating
to kids content.
We boost you up.
And you get recognized in the
store with the family star
badge, which is something
that our users look
for to understand whether or
not your app is family friendly.
We also collect more
information about the target age
of your app, the specific
category that you're targeting.
This actually helps us
do more on the back end
to make sure that we're
actually pushing the right apps
to the right types of users.
Now, whether you're part of
the Design for Families program
or not, the way
that kids interact
with Google and
Android APIs does
require some
additional tweaking,
so we're going to dive
into that a bit right now.
OK, so let's talk about ads.
This is probably the
area that most of you
want to know the most about.
Now, if your app is targeting
kids as part of its audience,
you probably know there are
a lot of legal requirements
for respecting child privacy in
different parts of the world.
And if you're using Admob
as one of your ad networks,
then Admob actually offers an
option for dealing with this.
And this is a
pretty simple thing.
When you basically go to
request an ad from Admob,
you just tag the ad request
in your app with a tag
that we call TFCD, and
that stands for Tag
For Child Directed Treatment.
This basically turns off
interest-based advertising
and re-marketing
in the ad request.
There's another
common requirement
in many parts of
the world, and this
is that the ad content you need
to display inside a kids' app
needs to be age appropriate.
When you need a
kid-friendly ad, Admob
does offer an option
for this as well.
This is what we call KFA, which
stands for Kid Friendly Ad.
So again, all you simply
do is tag your ad request
with this particular
tag and we'll actually
deliver kid friendly content in
the advertisement to your app.
Now if you're
participating in the Design
for Families program, and
your primarily targeting kids,
Google will automatically
tag your ad requests,
so you don't have to do
that work on your end.
But otherwise, you'll
need to make sure
that you're actually adding this
into your ad request directly.
Now, you may have noticed
that we also recently started
displaying this little label
on the details pages for apps.
And this is a little
label that tells
users hey, my app
actually contains ads,
because this is one of
our top feature requests
from parents on the Play Store.
Since this past January,
in Developer Console
you'll notice that there's a
section where you can actually
tell us yes, my app does
in fact contain ads,
and this will actually help
speed up your review process.
We know that everyone
is always eager
to get their apps on to the
store as soon as possible,
so make sure that
you're actually
checking this box if your app in
fact does contain advertising.
Now let's talk about
Google Play Games services.
Has anyone here tried out
the auto login feature
that we recently
launched in February?
No?
Maybe not.
OK.
Well you should check it out.
Play Games, as you
know, offers a variety
of features like leader
boards, achievements,
multi-player games, and even
video recording inside the app.
Now unfortunately,
we can't necessarily
offer these features to
children under the age of 13,
since Google accounts are made
for children ages 13 and up,
or users aged 13 and up
So here's really
the key takeaway
for developers of kids' apps.
First, if your app is really
primarily targeting just
children, you shouldn't
integrate the game service.
Really, really basic.
Now, if your app is targeting
both kids and adults,
you can integrate the
Play Games service,
you just need to make
sure that it's optional.
There's two different
implementation options
when you read through
this in our documentation.
You just need to
make sure that you
choose the optional
implementation rather
than the auto login version.
Another really great
feature for kids is speech,
and using voice-based
applications
makes a lot of sense for kids'
apps because a lot of our users
they don't [INAUDIBLE]
yet, they don't necessarily
know how to spell well and
they're probably not typing
that proficiently on a device.
So, as you know, Android
offers a world class speech
API which can be used to power
things like voice search,
like we have here in
our YouTube kid's app.
Now, audio recording is
a sensitive privacy area
for kids' apps, and
we know some of you
may be wary about adding
these types of features
because you didn't know
how to go about it.
Well, I'm happy to tell you that
the Android speech API actually
offers a way for
you to tell us when
you want us to treat the voice
search requests in your app
with more sensitivity.
Similar to the ad situation,
all you need to do
is send a special tag
with your request,
and if you're part of the
Design for Families program,
again, we take care
of this for you
and we're actually tagging
all of your voice requests
on your behalf on the back end.
Finally, the most important
tip of the day: you
don't have to keep
this all in your head.
You don't have to furiously
scribble down notes.
We'll be including all of
this material in a new section
in our Developer
Policy Center that's
called Kids and Families This is
coming in June, and all of this
will be covered in detail
with obviously a lot more
technical instruction on how to
do the ad tagging, et cetera.
So with that, I'm going
to hand it over to Shazia,
because we've discussed how
to build your app in a family
friendly way.
Now let's talk about how
to build your business
on Google Play as a kids' app.
SHAZIA MAKHDUMI: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE] Nice job,
[INAUDIBLE] Hi everyone,
I'm Shazia Makhdumi,
and for those I haven't met, I
lead our BD team for Families
and Education,
which means I work
with a lot of the
developers in the audience.
How many family or
kids' apps and games
developers in the
audience today?
OK, cool, excellent.
For those who have been to
any of my presentations,
I like to keep it
interactive and ask
you questions because
I get bored of hearing
myself speak all the time.
By the way, before we
start, how many people
prefer-- who have been to I/O
at Moscone in past years--
raise your hand if you've been
to I/O before at the Moscone
Center.
Of these, how many
prefer this location?
I share your sentiments.
OK, that was a quick poll for
feedback to the events team,
but anyway.
We'll get started.
Eunice talked a lot about
some of the policies designed
for families.
As you think about building
family, mixed age, or purely
kids directed apps,
we want to share
some feedback we've gotten from
more developers and from users.
So tablet optimization is
really important as something
we've heard, and in
fact 60% of our spend
for family apps
in the Play Store
comes from tablets, which is
unlike any other category.
And this is not a
surprise, because when
you think about it, your
parents have phones, which
yes is a very personal device.
They may give it to their
kid at a restaurant,
but your tablet is kind of your
family or living room device,
we've seen.
In fact, a recent poll we
conducted of kids, especially
younger kids, they actually
say they prefer playing
on tablets than on phones.
We have a tablet
optimization checklist
on android.developer.com,
so you should definitely
check that out to make sure that
you are ready for-- your app is
optimized for tablets.
One of my favorite questions.
How many people here have
used alpha and beta testing?
It's still a low percentage,
though better than the two
hands I typically get.
And out of those, how
many-- have you guys
used open beta at all, which is
something we launched recently?
OK.
Closed beta?
OK, cool.
So basically for those
who may not be familiar,
alpha and beta testing is
a way for you to check out
new app features you
may be launching,
or even your new app, to a
smaller group of select users
before you launch it out
to the world in general.
And this allows
them to check it,
to give you feedback, for you
to catch bugs and fix them
before it's released into
kind of the big wide world
and any bugs affect your rating.
So with an open beta, it can be
open to pretty much anyone who
wants it, though you can
cap the amount of people.
You don't have to worry about
creating that beta community.
But if you only want to use
it for a specific audience,
then you have the option of
creating a closed community
with the list of emails to be
beta testers off your content.
And in fact, at I/O, we
launched the ability for you to,
if you have an
open beta, for user
to sign into that from
the store listing itself.
So if I go into
the store listing,
and an app has an open beta,
I can select to beta the app.
For a select group
of apps, we'll
be featuring them in
a collection, called
an early access
collection, to expose
our users to really promising
open betas that are not
in production yet.
Another audience question.
Who's used promo codes so far?
OK, cool.
Who knows about promo codes?
I'm going to assume
everyone else wants
to know about promo codes, so
I'm going to talk about that.
So basically promo
codes is something
we launched a couple
of months ago,
and it's the ability for you
to create up to 500 promo codes
and have a self-serve
promo code campaign.
Instead of having
to work with Google
and figure out how to get
promo codes in front of users,
for up to 500 users, you
can create a promo code
and send it out so they can
experience your app or part
of the content for free.
So this would be really
useful for things
like, if there's a certain group
of influencers who you want
to get your app out to, or
a group of let's say parent
evangelists, or even if there's
a marketing campaign you're
doing to a target set of users.
So you can basically
run this on your own
from the developer console.
And then store
listening experiments--
actually I won't ask
about this since I
do know that 70% of
our top developers
are using store
listing experiments
and this has been an
extremely popular feature.
With this, what you
can do as you know,
is change the text, the
graphics, icons, et cetera,
to see what do users respond to.
We've actually gotten
feedback, especially
from kids and the
developers of kids' apps,
that kids love icons and
colors, and that's typically
the first thing they gravitate
towards when they select
an app to purchase or download.
And so getting that right
is really important.
One of our top
partners, Baby First,
experimented with a
couple of different icons,
and they found that using a
different icon for their app
actually increase
the installs by 10%.
And so they ended up
converting to that icon.
Rovio has tried a bunch
of different experiments,
and in fact now, all of their
launches are soft launches.
They get the A/B testing
to get their listing right,
and then they launch their
app to the general public.
We also recently, I think
it was as soon as last week,
announced that you can actually
run up to five store listing
experiments at a time.
Reviews and ratings
are really important.
How many people have
responded to user reviews?
OK, good.
So reviews and ratings
matter in the family space
more than other categories.
Reason being, and I see
this in myself as a parent,
parents look to other
parents for ideas,
inspiration, things on
what to get their kids,
stuff that will help their kids.
One of the main things they
go to is ratings and reviews.
But these are two
way streets, right?
So you want to help build up
that community so people will
engage with your app,
leave reviews, tell
their friends about it.
And we also recently had
announced the ability for you
to respond to reviews,
which I'm glad
quite a few people are
availing themselves of.
One of the things
we saw that when,
especially if you
have low reviews,
and you respond
to those reviews,
quite a few users end up
then changing their rating.
And they end up
raising the rating
by an average of
about 0.7 stars,
which is enough to get you over
maybe into the next star rating
category.
And star rating really
matters, because people equate
star rating with quality.
We've seen a very strong
correlation between quality
and revenue, so getting
that rating important
and doing whatever it
takes is really important.
Because we recognize that,
we've done a lot of stuff
on that in the
developer console.
So there's the ability to
look at ratings and reviews
by time segment, by country.
In fact, one of my favorites
is review highlights,
so you can see what are the
top themes that people are
talking about your app or game.
It may be very
different from what
you thought your app
or game was about,
and people are responding
to something else.
And that helps you change your
marketing campaign, or think
about an audience you
may have not considered.
We also recently released
review benchmarks,
which lets you compare your
app to other similar apps
in your category
across common topics,
like speed or
stability, et cetera,
so you can see how your
app compares to those-- how
do your ratings compare
to other similar apps
across those dimensions,
and make any fixes.
We also allow you
the ability to be
able to measure your rating on
topics specific to your app,
and see where it is that
you are falling behind
so you can make improvements.
We recognize how important
ratings and reviews are,
so there will be a
lot of effort made
to help you understand
them and make them go up.
So switching gears a
little bit, how many people
here use subscription
as a business model?
OK, cool.
So this chart actually shows
the growth in subscriptions
on Google Play.
There are a lot
more apps and games
that are using this
as a business model.
We have been doing
a lot of stuff
on our end to make sure
it's easy for developers
to be able to run a
subscription business.
So things like the period, a
weekly, monthly, quarterly,
annual subscription, the ability
to have grace periods, goodwill
credits, et cetera.
Yesterday, I was
talking to a developer.
One of the best
compliments we got
was when they mentioned
that our subscription
product and the way to
manage subscriptions on Play
is head and shoulders
above other platforms.
I was very happy to hear that.
Freemium is another
model that actually
is pretty popular on Play.
Among the kids' developers here,
how many people use Freemium?
OK.
So one may think you know
what, in app purchases, kids,
is that really appropriate?
Should we really be showing
kids in app purchases?
Well, Story Toys is one
of our top partners.
When they launched
Chuggington, they
saw that for Chug Patrol,
on the Freemium version,
they actually got about 250x
more downloads, and 3x more
revenue than the
premium version, which
led them to actually then launch
their new app, My Very Hungry
Caterpillar, as
Freemium on Play.
And it's seen strong
revenue and downloads.
Barry can chat more with you on
that if you have any questions.
And I also want to point out,
we don't have any restrictions
on having IAP in the kid's
section, on family section,
and in Google Play.
What we do have, though, as
Eunice mentioned earlier,
is the ability for password
protection for IAP purchases,
so we can make sure it's
parents who are approving
the purchase and not kids.
OK, so we went over
quite a few things,
and you'll hear a
lot more hopefully
at I/O. In fact, I think
the next session here--
next session in the
amphitheater at 11:00
is about what's new
in Google Play, which
we go into more detail
on some of the things
I've talked about.